vous avez écrit un livre incroyable vous
parlez de tout une des affaires qui a
fait le plus parler dans le football ces
dernières années c'est le cas benzema le
joueur n'est plus appelé en équipe de
france depuis 2016 sadi nice carrément
la france
tout est parti d'une histoire de sextape
est ce que pour y raconter à nos
téléspectateurs c'est une affaire
judiciaire au premier premier degré
c'est à dire qu'à un jour en
rassemblement équipe de france karim
benzema vient voir mathieu valbuena midi
gauche secte empêtré dans une affaire de
sextape et que on veut de faire chanter
moi j'ai peut-être une solution pour toi
j'ai quelqu'un tu veux qui t'appelle tu
veut l'appeler alors la justice dira s
qui voulait vraiment rend le service à
mathieu ou comme karim le dis comme
comme karim le prétend ou est-ce qu' il
était du côté d'un de ses copains qui
connaissait les maîtres chanteurs c'est
pas établie du tout toujours est il que
les deux jours à partir de ce moment là
ce sont un peu exclu
et après
[Musique]
les choses sont ce soit un peu calmée et
il ya eu des incidents qui ont fait que
didier n'a pas sélectionné karim et
scellier scellier à à une histoire de
l'avs
la non sélection de karim a entraîné de
la part d'eric cantona et d'autres
personnes des commentaires à connotation
raciste
alors c'est ça l'histoire narre faé ben
slema sont pas là c'est de par leurs
origines etc
c'est ce qu'on a dit parce que quelques
mois plus tard karim benzema donne une
interview en espagne dans laquelle il
sous-entend que didier deschamps il y
aurait cédé une partie raciste de la
france et pas la maison même de didier
deschamps paraît-il il parie avec le mot
raciste voilà on arrive au bout de la
faire ouais
donc quand on a fait ces déclarations
karim benzema dit oui le sélectionneur
je dis pas qu'il est raciste mais il a
pu céder une partie de la population
française bien plus raciste et un jour
la maison des la femme de didier de
concarneau la maison des champs à
concarneau est taguée avec le mot
raciste et didier je l' ai vu ce jour là
très marqué je ne dis pas que karim ne
reviendra pas en équipe de france ça
seul didier peut le dire mais j'ai
l'impression que ce jour là une ligne
rouge a été franchie mais voilà est-ce
qu'il s'est expliqué un jour avec karim
à dire parce que je sais que didier
deschamps
comme vous l'avez dit a été très très
meurtrie 1 par cette histoire et part je
sais pas c'est que les gens ne savaient
pas s'ils ont bien parlé
on vous en avait parlé avec karim
benzema depuis deux ans je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de gemmes pur comme ça il
paraît que didier deschamps aurait même
refusé de participer à l'émission au
tableau en 2018 à cause d'une phrase de
jamel debbouze sur didier effectivement
je raconte dans mon livre que l'émission
au tableau de mes listes et mélissa
theuriau saint-thuriau didier avait
donné son accord il avait commencé à
travailler avec alexandre darmon sur les
thèmes de l'émission va tous se
présentait bien et puis dans l'émission
qui précédait jamel debbouze a eu un
petit mot papa pas méchant homme enfin
est à dire si karim pour revenir en
équipe de france serait bien une vie et
m'a dit tu annules tout mais parce que
dis je crois que c'est une profonde de
la blessure il a dit aussi qu'il a été
meurtri de pas avoir d'explications
aussi avec didier deschamps
la trame urbaine c'est énorme malentendu
qui est parti d'une affaire judiciaire
et après les positions sont écartées
parce que je veux dire moi je connais
des deux c'est vrai que karim c'est
vraiment un mec que j'aime beaucoup
bien sûr je m'entends très bien c'est un
jeu didier deschamps et didier deschamps
c'est un mec d'une simplicité
voilà qu'une la chance de rencontrer
bonne foi et qui a une famille très très
simple mais sa femme cdc avant d amour
mais serait donc c'est ça fait c'était
triste parce que je pense ça c'est parti
d'un malentendu et ça s'est envenimée
aujourd'hui les deux sons sont pénalisés
par ce qui se passe